president Trump's attorney Jay Sekulow
is now calling for a second special
counsel to be appointed to investigate
the massive conflicts of interest
surrounding a key Department of Justice
official and Fuzion GPS now the company
behind the Clinton bought and paid for
fake Trump anti Trump propaganda from
Russia while that dossier this comes
after a Fox News exclusive report
showing that in fact the wife of Bruce
or the recently demoted DOJ official
actually worked for fusion GPS during
the 2016 election while it was crafting
that fake news dossier
now also tonight the fake news media
they're working overtime by spreading
outright lies misinformation to try and
damage and discredit President Trump
here are some of the recent examples on
Friday CNN they ran wild with a fake
news report about Donald Trump jr.
claiming that he received an email on
September the 4th 2016 that gave him
special access to hack DNC emails that
were not released at that point by
WikiLeaks that was a total lie because
the email was sent that was actually
sent from September 14th that was the
day after WikiLeaks had published the
DNC emails also fake news CNN they were
pushing that story for hours and others
like conspiracy TV MSNBC they repeated
it before the Clinton news network
finally offered a correction and over
the weekend the Washington Post reporter
Dave Weigel tweeted out this fake news
photo and claimed that the arena was
empty during a Trump rally in Florida
turns out the photos well they were
taken well before the president even
stepped onstage
and why whoa Michael in this particular
case was forced to apologize it was an
outright lie the New York Times
published a story claiming the President
Trump
watches up to eight hours of TV a day
and drinks 12 diet cokes huge news now
CNN has since been using that so-called
report to wildly speculate about
president Trump's health and a pretty
despicable display last week both
Bloomberg Reuters they put out the fake
news story that the special counsel
Robert Muller's team had subpoenaed
President Trump and his family's bank
records from Deutsche Bank now president
Trump's legal team quickly pushed back
and by the way those outlets also issued
Corrections and finally of course there
was ABC News
Brian Ross he was suspended without pay
for reporting that Lieutenant General
Michael Flynn was prepared to testify
that then candidate Trump ordered him to
contact the Russians that turned out to
be false
he's also forbidden for ever reporting
on Donald Trump going forward joining us
now with reaction
the attorney for president Trump Jay
Sekulow you were involved today I
actually saw your text messages to NBC
where you said you're not calling for a
special counsel for a special counsel to
be appointed for robert muller at all
could we've said it three times in that
same text exchange right so here's what
you had I mean Sean this was a really
straightforward situation when the news
broke yesterday about Bruce or and the
conversations he had with using GPS and
Chris Steele which by the way supposedly
was done without the knowledge of is a
those in authority over him although he
was very high-ranking the the fourth in
the line of authority at the Department
of Justice we then find out that not
only is he meeting with fusion GPS and
Christopher Steele who wrote the fake
dossier but that I mean you cannot make
this stuff up that that Bruce or his
wife was working at the same time for
fusion GPS and was their expert on
Russia
so we said when we saw this yesterday
with my colleagues we discussed the
issue in and decided that the best
course of action here in our view as
lawyers was that a special counsel be
appointed as by the way Chuck Grassley
has stated as has Lindsey Graham stated
to look into all of this because as I
said in my statement the conflicts of
interest with inside the FBI and
Department of Justice as to this fusion
GPS matter is is breathtaking in scope
now NBC got that we I was clear as you
saw three times in an email a text
exchanged with the main reporter on this
and then NBC runs and says the story
exactly opposite I said this is nothing
to do with Bob Muller we've been
cooperating with Bob Muller I'm very
encouraged and I'm very not only
encouraged I will tell you this this has
been one transparent administration when
it comes to what's been done here and
what's been provided to the
special counsel and I'm very convinced
that we're gonna have a successful
conclusion having said that I never said
a word
Shawn not one touch the opposite a
special counsel for the said just the
opposite J exactly the opposite and that
is again I asked them to retract the
story they did in some of their news
reports but one of the MSNBC hosts took
what was said incorrectly by NBC ran
with it and still to this moment has not
retracted it although he's put my full
statement is but this is you put that on
top of Deutsche Bank the fake love
picture from the packed rally in
Pensacola the incorrect statements from
CNN on as you mentioned on the whole
situation on those emails with WikiLeaks
and getting the date wrong with
supposedly three sources I'm going to
just tell the American people tonight
that we are going to give you that
what's actually happening here and
you're seeing it in
unfortunately play out before your eyes
but the good news is I am very
encouraged that we'll be bringing this
to accessible conclusion let me bring up
what this breaking news that we have
tonight let me let me set the table a
little bit we know this or literally
four doors down from Rosenstein we know
that he was meeting with fusion GPS they
the firm that was hired they came up
with the false dossier hired Christopher
steel just to give some background turns
out now his wife worked for fusion GPS
now here's where it gets worse Peter
struck and his girlfriend Lisa Paige
both of them working in just at Peter
struck in particular he was in the the
dossier case he interviewed Cheryl Mills
he interviewed Huma Abedin he
interviewed Hillary Clinton he was there
for the interview with general Flynn it
seems like the FBI only has one
full-time employee because he's involved
in all of this I am looking at the text
messages that have now been released new
where his girlfriend is calling Donald
Trump a loathsome human being where they
are praising Hillary Clinton these are
people that are supposed to be involved
in an objective and fair investigation
of individuals now we know in the case
of omen Abidine and Cheryl Mills they
both lied
they were in charge like general Flynn
in other words we have a case where
Peter struck James Comey literally were
writing an exoneration before the
investigation in the Hillary Clinton's
email let's talk about him well I mean
first of all Peter struck was Robert
Muller was taken off the case and
apparently a numbness know this for a
fact
this was the reason so that's that's
that's one question right there he was
by the way and one of the leading
counter and supposedly one of the
leading counterintelligence FBI agents
in the in the bureau but he was taken
off the case and has been reassigned to
human resources so obviously there was a
concern that the Special Counsel had
with regard to his capability in moving
forward on this in an objective manner
as it's supposed to be under the law but
you you laid out the James Comey matter
and I you know here's Sean there's
another aspect of this that tends to get
overlooked and that were 16 witnesses
were given immunity by the FBI and
Department of Justice and the whole
investigation on the emails and he wrote
that exoneration letter before before he
the interviews of those witnesses took
place so you know explain that you can't
okay you could say the fix was in
and Peter saw what was involved in this
by the way God Hillary should win you
know a hundred million to zero I guess
we hear worst political affiliations
lies yeah but here's here's the biggest
point though I mean from a legal
standpoint here so on this is what's
significant because of this apparently
he's removed but look at the issue in a
more global sense why is it that the
Federal Bureau of Investigation there
are a lot of great agents out there we
know that that put their lives on the
line every day for all of us our
families but why is it that when you
have you go back to the Bruce or and the
the dossier did that dossier for
instance serve as the basis for FISA
warrants Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Act warrants why can't we
get an answer look great questions we
should be able to get an answer I think
look I think the Attorney General owes
the American people an answer on that
and and should give it forthwith and of
course Congress has subpoenaed to get
answers on all these questions but I
want everybody to think about that for a
moment you had a FISA warrant that may
have been issued on a dossier that was
with all of this inter you know nicey
the aspects going on here and at the end
of the day you have to say how is this
allowed to continue why is this not why
are these people not terminate it and
you know what the answer that is it's
that people don't like when you say it
but it is the deep state it's the
bureaucrats because you know what they
haven't talked about because there's no
evidence of it the president talking
with Russians meeting with Russians
meaning with Russian although all the
Russia talk that's taking place now for
a year as this has now been you know
fully headed there was nothing there but
you know what
then we very quickly doesn't paid for
dossier with Russia lies propaganda to
influence the 2016 election we go take
it as but take it right back into the
Department of Justice Sean and how is it
that the fourth ranking DOJ official is
wife works for the company that's
putting together the dossier and and and
that should just be ok because the media
believe me the media would not have
covered what happened today on this
unless NBC would have put out the
incorrect statement this would have
gotten no attention I mean James Rosen
did a great job of reporting it but it
wasn't getting play at all and now it
has to because of NBC's incorrect
statement all right chase we appreciate
your time when we come back